i want to tell you what happened this
week when i spoke to arthur laffer
at arthur lampheron and i asked him i
said what concerns you the most
right i said tell me what you think
about all these all this talk about
inflation you know how prices are up you
know lumber went up it's back down a
little bit you know all these things
that we care about you know
gas all this other stuff you know home
prices for the first time the median
home prices just reached 350 000
page seven that hasn't happened this is
a new record that we have so
inflation is in place i said arthur how
concerned are you about inflation
he says not at all i said why not he
says because the leading indicator of
inflation is gold and gold hasn't moved
goes the same that it's been so i don't
think inflation is an issue what do you
think about the
severity or the real issue of inflation
is it real or is it just
you know something that's going to come
and go so you know one of the worst
areas has been freight shipping costs
what have you
uh we've seen that begin to turn that's
huge that's going to be huge for
companies to have their
supply delivery time start to come down
so that's one of your sources we've
obviously seen commodities turn
i mean copper is down today every
company's biggest
cost item is labor 60 65
of any company in this country is labor
if you have wage inflation you've got a
problem and if you have true wage
inflation then you're going to see it in
gold
just like he said and we don't know what
true wage inflation is or is not until
we refill the labor pool
and we're not there yet you know we've
got 10 states coming off
over the weekend ending their federal
unemployment benefits early
we had two blue states joining the band
these last few days louisiana maryland
two democratic states who crossed the
line would it be considered a blue state
why
i'm talking about their governors oh
gotcha governor because the governor's
got to sign it and i mean the
government's gotta agree your governor
don't agree you're dead
got it okay so we've actually states are
starting to come on board saying uh uh
you're not just gonna sit home and
collect checks anymore get your ass back
to work well i mean the chambers of
commerce the small business coalitions
everybody's like
we need these workers yeah we absolutely
need these workers
and so i i think to laffer's point
talk to me after labor day talk to me
after september the 6th when these
unemployment benefits finally exhaust
themselves
president biden himself has miracle of
all miracles said he's not going to
re-extend them
they're just they're too many people who
are like this was a huge fiscal
backfire we didn't need to do this so
the unemployment checks and
all the multiple stimulus yes i mean
people are making double what they would
have made
yeah and i'm not talking look i
understand that everybody needs a
workable living wage i mean i get
skewered for this on twitter
but i actually had somebody on my
twitter feed yesterday say if we have to
sacrifice u.s small businesses
so be it and i was like who said that i
was like what
because i well i'm like look if we put
because 39.8 percent of u.s small
businesses are still not
open post-pandemic wait say that again
38.9 of u.s small businesses
remain closed post pandemic era
in the beginning a lot of them you're
telling a restaurant you can only open
up
25 capacity or 50 capacity but you're
also telling them out of the other side
of your mouth
if you want to get government loans
through the ppp program you've got to
use 75
of the funds for employees and you're
like as a small business owner you're
like well what which is it
i'm not allowed to increase my
employment beyond 50
capacity if i'm joking restaurant owner
but 75 of the loans have to be earmarked
for labor
no no go so as a result we've got the
biggest companies getting bigger and
bigger and bigger because chipotle
or bank of america or amazon god help us
they can all afford to pay up but they
know they're paying up
for a a finite period of time meanwhile
back at the ranch you're sticking it to
small business owners who cannot compete
so you know how much common sense does
it take to know that that's not a good
strategy i just looked at it
now i'm going to send you this story
47.3
that's insane from a couple days ago
our small businesses 47.3 and do we
really want to wake up tomorrow and be
like big box retailer monopoly america
with no culture no soul so that's the
thing
look i started off now hold your horses
i started off at little
little caesar's pizza pizza pizza pizza
and but there was a starting job
and i was a teenager right now teenagers
are having the best
summer since 2008 because they're paying
teenagers 18 bucks an hour
they're like i can do this for three
months asleep are you kidding me
so they're taking these entry-level jobs
teenagers and we're seeing
and and that's fantastic because you
know what we need we need a new
generation of kids who understands that
they need to work
and not dictate the terms of employment
to their employers which we're seeing
a lot of right now because employees
have negotiating power
because there's still so many people who
are on the sidelines so
talk to me after labor day when all of
this goes away is there anything you're
speculating on what you will you foresee
happening
or is it all like i don't know until i
see what happens
well there is a flashlight can you go
back to that please go back to the
article please right 38.9
the data from the opportunity thank you
small business shutdown pandemic nearly
40 percent
the data from opportunity insight shows
that 38.9 small businesses were
closed as of june 2nd
that's insane to me to be thinking about
that how
okay your joe q small business how are
you competing with amazon
you're you don't have a thousand dollar
signing bonus you don't
the the data compiled by small business
marketing service one play is based on
credit and debit card transactions
a business was marked as closed if there
was no transactions for three
consecutive days
beginning march first businesses that
conducted all their i mean that's a good
way of doing it i mean if you're not
getting any credit you're not getting
any revenue then you're not open
yeah so here's my question if this is 40
38.9 whatever across the board across
the usa that is the united states okay
so
in florida we've been open the whole
time like uh
are there any you have to realize that
the last year and a half you've lived in
two states we did it right texas and
florida so you don't know any other so
my point is this and our schools were
open so our labor pools were not as
depleted because we didn't force the
moms onto the sidelines
like like the teacher union cities
chicago and la and new york
so you've got a couple million women out
of the workforce as well who are also
going to feed back into the labor pool
after schools reopen in the fall they're
finally going to be able to go back to
work
because they're not going to be
controlled effectively by teachers
unions who do not advocate by the way
for kids
they advocate for themselves well it's
not safe in the get a vaccination
shut up and get in the classroom and
teach or find a different profession
but don't hold the moms of this country
hostage hmm
but by the way just just a crazy thing
on what happened the last podcast so the
last podcast two days ago whatever was
tues was it tuesday or was it monday
monday that we did uh we showed cole
beasley's tweet
okay on why his uh opinions on vaccine i
won't even get into it so
cole beasley's tweet we read we put the
show
easily the football player yeah he said
what he said about vaccine
we put his tweet up on short clips
valuetainment short clips
within a few hours it was taken down and
the channel got a strike and our
valuetainment short clips channel
suspended for one week
just because we read his tweet
we read his tweet that we read his tweet
and i said
my dad got the shot my auntie got my
nanny got the shot melva pops
we talk about the tweet it was taken
down
what's the lesson there but well look
there this the
this should not be censorship usa this
is
what it is but but the point is that's a
little too much but
you can't even have an opinion to say
we're talking to phil heat bodybuilder
tell me what you think about this we're
talking with gerard we're
we're talking with tom basic
conversation so
uh uh uh it's i mean we're allowed to be
a self-directed
nation but by the same token if you're
an employer you're also allowed to
dictate the terms of employment
so there are two huge sides to this
argument right now but you
but we have liberty we can do whatever
we want if we don't want to get
vaccinated
fine we're not vac if our employer says
we have to get vaccinated
and you want to keep working for them
get vaccinated it's it's a
it's a pretty black and white decision
it is a pretty black and white decision
but it's
it's it doesn't seem like it's a one
it's a
a decision that you can have an opposing
argument to
that's what's a challenge right now it
seems like it's a decision that you
either agree with us or you don't
or else you know it's not like hey you
got a
second opinion do you want to get a you
know first doctor is right and this is
what you better do or else it's a little
by the way you know to be honest with
you if you think about it long term
think about
the ramifications of that long term that
is a pretty annoying place to live
if you can't have an opposing idea what
a place to live
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye